Can you tell me what supplements are antioxidants besides my greens first
drink? So the greens first drink, yeah there's some antioxidants in there. I
would not classify that as an antioxidant to stop taking for the 48 hours
during the cable. I would keep taking that. The only thing that I would stop
taking during the 48 hours I certainly would do any vitamin C either oral or IV
vitamin C. I wouldn't do that. I wouldn't do alpha-lopeic acid. I wouldn't do
glutathione. Those are the really three main things. Curcumin is an antioxidant.
Maybe you want to stop that. I would not stop the green drink. So I'd say
curcumin, alpha-lopeic acid, and glutathione. Those are the three main things
that I'd stop. Those are the most really the more powerful antioxidants. I mean
you're eating food that's got antioxidants. It's not you're like trying to
eliminate all antioxidants. You just try to eliminate like really high dose
things that would negate some of the chemo. A lot of alternative doctors don't even
suggest that. They say that you should load up on antioxidants while you're
even for those 48 hours. They say you should they just don't stop people for
doing it. I think contrary to that, I think just give it 48 hours off of that. You
could certainly fast all your supplements for those 40 hours if you want. But
you do your other cells do need nutrition too. I said they wouldn't stop the green